hey guys this is andrew for
trainsenses.com i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and i've started a few months ago to do
some youtube videos
uh because i want to show you guys how
pro traders actually working
and i want to be i want to connect the
two sides you know
of like between the pro traders and the
you know retail investors because i've
been one of them
and i have a lot of people that come to
me my family my close friends that want
to get some information they're asking
me for advice
and i really enjoy sharing with them my
experience about you know market
dynamics about you know how we actually
do our analysis as per traders
and what i see on this market so if you
want to know about all the stuff
uh you are in the right place so today i
want to make a big update on the
cryptocurrency which has been a crazy
market this week
and i want to show you guys what are my
key levels let's get into it
[Music]
so let's start with uh the king bitcoin
is the king it's the crypto that is
performing the best they have
around now i think 1 000 billion market
capitalization so it's
a lot and what is happening guys so
basically i was saying on my previous
videos i do like regular updates on this
you can check
and uh it's not always like this but on
bitcoin guys for now i have like a clean
sheet i'm always
right about what i'm saying uh it's not
going to be like this forever
because this is you know technical
analysis is about probabilities and
expected gains
so for now you know i've been let's say
lucky in my analysis but at least i got
it all
good so what i'm seeing now so basically
we broke this triangle two weeks ago
here tesla elon musk were buying uh you
know a few billions of
bitcoin so it was the signal that the
market was waiting for
to push higher right now what is
happening so guys you are all asking me
should i buy more here
you know even here i was saying no you
know i was saying wait for every test
maybe
of 38 000 this consideration level and
then you can buy more
of course it went higher of course you
missed uh you know some
profits but guys this is not a few days
game
it's a you know long term game if you
want to be profitable in the long term
you cannot buy you know the middle of a
breakout you know even buying here
would not be a good idea uh buying here
which i was saying guys i
told you i gave you this trade i say i
was saying we had to break out it was
confirmed
it's retesting and here was a very nice
area to buy it
all right people who bought it here i
did not agree i was saying guys we're
having some resistance level now that
are
in line which are my fib extension
ratios
and i think the market is gonna correct
and consolidate and then we'll see and
this is what happens so right now guys
what to do if you are long of course you
keep it
you keep it uh we are going to 55 000
once again
look here what happened so this is the
2.618
retracement ratio and not retracement
extension and this was the 1.618 so
we're just going from one to the other
one
so the same situation is likely to
happen guys so we might
you know just get rejected go higher and
just
hover around it for now what you need to
look for guys
very important listen to this uh you
need to find the moving averages that
are fitting the
uh price action so here i have 20 50 200
i just look you know i'm on the four
hours time frame it works on every time
frame guys
you just take a time frame take some
moving averages and check what is
working
and this will give you some signals of
when it's time to maybe
take some profits for now uh the 20
period moving average has been broken
here
and here so it's not a good indicator
all right
here it was broken it's not what the
bitcoin is following
then you have the 50 guys the 50 period
moving average has been
working here guys as a nice support
level it was perfect
signals here slightly breached but not
uh for full hours that's why it's
important to get
a confirmation of every breakout i
encourage you guys
to go check my videos on the breakout
that i did three weeks ago
where i explained how to deal with
breakouts and now you can see guys
that uh it's again acting as support so
here it was support
here not really touched but it's all
right so this is
your safety line guys all right when the
bitcoin is breaking it
for more than four hours all right so
let's say eight hours you have two
consecutive candles on the four hours
time frame that are trading below this
this is the time guys to take some
profits all right i'm not saying to
unwind all your position i'm just saying
guys this is
weakness that the bitcoin is showing for
now we don't have it
all right we don't have it we're pushing
higher with a nice
uh pace all right it's regular there is
only you know the moves down they're not
strong
for now there is not any profit taking
everybody that is long is keeping the
position and that right to do so
so once again how i find uh my
resistance levels so if you go on the
weekly time frame
all right so once again guys this is my
idiot wave analysis on the bitcoin
it's pure it's not often like this
this one is perfect it's fitting
everything
since inception one two three four five
abc
one two three four five abc zigzag flat
you know it's always like this when the
two is zigzag then the four is usually a
flat this is what happened
and each third wave can be broken into
five waves as well so guys uh if you
want to know more about idiot wave
principle uh click on the link in the
description of the video and you're
gonna receive a free video on this
so here what is happening we are doing
the fifth wave
what is telling me where the fifth wave
is gonna go
fibonacci i measure the third wave
i apply it to the fourth wave uh to the
bottom of the fourth or the fifth wave
which is the same button which is here
and i follow my ratios guys all right
it's not rocket science and it's working
right on the bitcoin
is working very well so 35 000 was
my first consolidation level and my next
one is at 55 000. so i'm not saying it's
not going to go above
like we said and the next one is 73 and
then 46 thousands
all right so one of those level is
probably gonna be the one
of the fifth wave and where is the fifth
wave going maybe to three
500 i don't know we're gonna analyze it
when it's gonna come
right now we are in the first wave of
this fixed wave
so it needs to of course pull back a
little bit
at a point but for now we are not
finished
guys so 55 000 next resistance level
once again
slightly above slightly below let's see
let's see
let's focus on those levels and do some
shorter term and
technical analysis when it arrives all
right very quickly on the ethereum
so the ethereum is uh giving us some
nice signals
it uh breached the all-time high and i
do the same kind of analysis i measured
this wave and i apply it to fifth wave
alright
and it gives me target of 2600
so i think the ethereum will go there
but the moves are
um so it's less than this it's 30
higher uh so this could be uh you know
compatible with a bitcoin going maybe to
60 000 something like this
so guys if you're long ethereum same
thing it's good to hold
uh careful you know we check what are
the moving averages that
uh work the best same guys the 50
on the daily time frame yeah here the 50
is working well
when we have moves up the 50 is working
well and when the 50
is break is broken then usually we have
some consolidation so you can
focus on this one i didn't do it very
well guys check the different time
frames check the different moving
averages
and select the one that is giving you
the best signals uh when we have
the uh similar moves next one ripple
so the ripple uh is very interesting so
guys just one thing
here i have the ripple that is colorful
and i have the bitcoin that is
in orange all right so you can see that
the bitcoin is over performing the
ripple
as all the other cryptocurrencies by a
lot
and uh what is interesting to notice is
what i said in the videos i did a few
weeks ago
so the uh the ripple is actually a
company guys they try to get regulated
they
talk with banks with you know central
banks regulators
this kind of people so all the big
players of the financial industry
and they want to get the coin regulated
so we don't really know if it's a coin
or a share
so they have some issues with that and
that's the reason why here
it went brutally down because the sec
was actually telling them
that they need to justify actually the
actions because there
are not a crypto blah blah blah it's not
what is interesting here what is
interesting guys
once again is technical analysis so we
can see that
already a few years ago the bitcoin is
doing its move and one month later
the ripple is doing its move why because
when the cryptos
are hot then those guys that are like in
the ripple company
they can on board a lot of companies
more easily and they have
some good you know dynamics going on the
industry which is the
cryptocurrencies that gonna allow them
to make some deals
and then they have usually some good
news and they release the good news and
then they have
this kind of crazy moves up so right now
what is the bitcoin doing
it started to go higher you can see guys
it goes higher here
the ripple goes higher here so one month
two months later
then second leg bam here one month later
bam each time it's coming back now we
have this one
so started 26th of jan so guys i expect
a strong move up on the ripple
on the 26th of feb so we are right now
the
19th of february so i'm not sure i'm
gonna release this video today maybe i'm
gonna have a few days
a delay but i'm telling you guys that
around
end of feb beginning of march we're
gonna have a strong move up on
the ripple so that's it for me i hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys